foreign
Matthew McConaughey and Camilla alvis's
kiddos make a rare public appearance at
Paris fashion week what better Legacy
could we leave behind
than
our children on Monday the McConaughey
kids Levi and Vida attended the Stella
McCartney fall winter 2023 show
alongside their mama that's a 14 year
old rocking a matching black and tan
tracksuit with a cream oversized jacket
and a pair of black sneakers looking a
whole lot like his A-list dad I love it
as for Vita the 13 year old is the
spitting image of her mom in a chic
white dress and a pair of mini Ugg boots
meanwhile Camilla looks Fab in a cream
pantsuit and black bra accessorizing
with a matching wide brim tat and
snakeskin boots they're fashionable
they're in the trend not in attendance
Matthew and their youngest kid 10 year
old Livingston our eldest is very clean
very balanced our middle girls like
um very coordinated and then there's the
youngest one who
you have to use young Livingston out of
bed and we can greet the day without
coming out of Rage Matthew may have
skipped Fashion Week but he was there
for this sweet family moment Camilla
shared the heartwarming snap on the gram
last month Levi watching as his little
bro Gets a Haircut from Dad as mom jokes
in the caption then this happened it's a
very neat thing you know something that
we do it at home the Oscar winner also
shared this proud dad moment last week
putting his son's surf souvenirs on full
display wherever you go surfing even if
there's no waves there's still a good
time shortly after Levi was born Matthew
told E.T they were already preparing him
to hit the waves we already start in the
water we haven't got him in the beach
yet but um so far there's nothing
natural like that like the water that
he's that he's afraid of so we'll just
slowly get him out there what a great
playground to grow up in and uh in the
Pacific Ocean if you can get out in the
saltwater that's going to be his pool
hopefully Anna if it if that's what he
digs but Matthew and Camilla are passing
on more than their hobbies to their kids
they're teaching them how to make an
impact we are fortunate to have a very
life I'm not you know having to to have
it having to worry if I can pay the rent
next week I'm thankful for that there's
a lot of people that do it it's very
grounding for us I think it's good it's
hopefully going to be grounding for our
children too to appreciate
every little thing and me I simply
appreciate a fabulous family celebrating
Fashion Week Matthew take it away all
right all right all right
how you doing
[Music]
foreign